hello everybody uh
welcome to my my talk today
uh which is on the subject of enabling
translation of biomarker research to
clinical practice
my name is fergus fleming and i am the
chief technology officer of reanalytics
a clinical diagnostics company
based out of uk and the us
i'm sitting here in ireland and we have
a technology center that i operate from
from here in ireland so
moving quickly along i wanted to just
briefly go to the agenda of the items i
want to cover today
i'll talk a little bit more about myself
and my background so that we can get
some context in terms of the perspective
that i'm coming from in relation to this
area of biomarker translation
we'll cover some of the key steps
involved in the in the journey from
biomarker research to abs absolute use
in clinical practice
as many of you will know there are many
stakeholders involved in this cycle of
development and translation and will
will to speak a little bit about who all
those stakeholders would be
and how and there are different roles
that it would play in enabling this this
translation
and then we'll wrap up with some uh
discussion on some key challenges and
and opportunities for how together we
can
make some progress in
in advancing this translation to a to a
higher level
on the next slide uh
speaking to myself my background really
is in the medical device and diagnostics
industry so i come from
the
industrial side of the actual design
development manufacturing and
and supply of medical technology and
i've
developed in the last 10 years in
particular quite a lot of experience in
the development and translation of in
vitro diagnostics across a number of
clinical spaces
including hemostasis coagulation
infectious diseases and and oncology
recently i've been spending a lot of
time working on advanced diagnostics
these are diagnostics that bring
together multiple biomarkers together
with other
data science and data features including
advanced algorithms
and addressing some specific needs in
the area of diagnostics and the broader
field of diagnostics which we'll discuss
later on
in so doing i've had a lot of
interaction with digital health and the
role that digital health plays in in the
current
clinical context
and also
traditional medical devices as well
my current role is with a company called
green analytics which was founded in
2018
with the objective
of converging and bringing the advancing
the convergence of biomarkers and data
to address unmet needs specifically in
chronicated disease so a lot of what we
will speak about today is is informed by
that context
the specific purpose that we're trying
to address right now in analytics is to
use diagnostics and biomarkers to
identify patients who are most at risk
of disease progression so these are
patients who already have a condition in
this case chronic kidney disease but
we're trying to
discriminate between patients who would
be most at risk for for progression and
therefore who would most benefit from
advanced care and advanced therapeutics
our lead product is called kidney
intellect
and it's designed as part of the overall
comprehensive solution for kidney health
so very briefly in relation to the
product itself
uh here we're talking we're taking three
biomarkers that have been widely
published in the literature
specifically the soluble children across
this factor one solid achievement across
factor two and kidney injury molecule
one
but we're combining that with the data
that's available and in a patient's
electronic health record to give us the
best source of the contemporary clinical
space of the patient and using a
validated algorithm to translate all of
that information into a piece of
actionable
instruction
we provide that through a test report
where we
communicate the risk profile of the
patients in in both a quantitative and
qualitative
presentation
low intermediate and high risk of
progression on a scale of 0 to 100.
notably what we do is
link that risk profile to to a set of
guideline informed actions that the
provider or the physician can take with
that patients to try and advance
and
preserve their kidney health
most of that is based on
on on established guidelines but in for
those of you who may be familiar with
chronic kidneys there's been a lot of
innovation and new developments in terms
of therapies in this area and some of
which have now been incorporated into
clinical guidelines so we want to
maximize the adherence to those clinical
guidelines by
by by highlighting where those new
medications can best be used
so that provides a general context for
for a lot of what we will speak about
later on in in the
in the talk
so what type of informational
information do biomarkers provide um
this is
you know for those of us in the
diagnostic industry you know one man's
diagnostic is another man's prediction
so what we try to do is ensure that we
are
at at the very
front of the translational pipeline
trying to understand what is the
actionable information what is the thing
that somebody will do differently as a
result of having that information
available
and across the spectrum of the disease
timeline there are a number of different
diagnostic tests where biomarkers would
play a role
for example
in the absence of any disease or in the
absence of any indications of disease
you have risk stratification or
screening biomarkers for example
one of those would be
psa for prostate cancer where
just because of age
one might be encouraged to have a
psa test which is a biomarker that is
indicative of some level of risk for
prostate cancer
moving on then you go to screening
biomarkers where now you've got some
evidence of disease and now you want to
screen the ones that are
are most likely to have the disease
some of those would include things like
cholesterol right where you have some
level of
risk factors now you measure cholesterol
as a screening test to say okay who's
who's the who are the patients who are
who are most likely to be
uh at most at risk for cardiovascular
disease
moving on to symptomatic disease you're
looking at your your straightforward
diagnosis so you're ruling in or ruling
out a condition using biomarkers
some examples of those would be
anti-pro-pmp which is a a measure of
an indicator of heart failure or the
potential for heart failure
hospitalization
and we've translated into diagnosis
treatment decisions and surveillance
monitoring we in particular in terms of
kidney intellect is very much in the
prognostic area where patients already
have a diagnosis but now we're looking
to see what is the prognosis for that
patient how do we differentiate a large
population of patients into into
different risk strata based on a
biomarker profile
that's
an area then that moves into knowing
those patients have a risk profile now
you want to ensure that they're going to
receive the appropriate care
that's where predictive biomarkers come
into play where now you want to know
after that whether the right therapy is
going to be picked for the right patient
this is often called
complementary diagnostics or companion
diagnostics
again you're answering a specific
question around a patient's risk and
matching that risk to a particular
therapy
and then moving on to using either the
same biomarkers or different biomarkers
to monitor the
disease progression and back to psa well
it is
a reasonably
contentious
test or a biomarker for for screening it
is actually quite an effective biomarker
for for monitoring of of existing
disease
so biomarkers play a significant role
right across the spectrum
and at the very beginning of any
biomarker translation process which is
something i repeat quite a bit is really
having a clear understanding of what the
what indicated use or the purpose
or or the actionable information would
be based on that biomarker or biomarker
test
in terms of the very first point and a
lot of you working in the research space
will know that
you know
lots of papers get published and lots of
associations are identified where a
biomarker is linked to a particular
outcome
and outcome definition is very important
and we'll speak a little bit about that
later on as well and one of the ways in
which people will traditionally assess a
biomarker against an outcome is looking
at the area under the curve as a measure
of of performance
once you get a reasonably high auc and
typically in a in an area discovery
cohort an auc
of 0.9 or better is typically something
that would be classified as a good a
good biomarker
now you move on to it say okay well does
it does it really add value
what are the things that
will be
reportable as a result of this biomarker
and you need to look at what this
biomarker does in the presence
of various other
clinical features so you're using things
like odds ratios risk ratios hazard
ratios to
to bring this biomarker into into a
context in relation to other clinically
uh relevant features if it doesn't pass
that test then it's just
informative in terms of it it has an
association but it's unlikely to be
helpful in terms of adding new
information upon which people can make
decisions
if that's not the case and you do have
clinically significant
discrimination of a value where this
biomarker is adding new information now
you've got something that you can move
into
the next realm of of investigation so
now you've got
a quantifiable improvement in in in the
information available from this
biomarker
and that really is the first
discovery or early
complications that would emerge from
from a biomarker research program
however a single
evident a single piece of evidence
around a biomarker is rarely enough
to to support
not only the
the endeavor required to move it further
along the development pipeline but also
the significant level of investment
required
so so what you're looking for in in good
in in the context of really good
biomarkers the ones that have been
extensively
studied and extensively validated
this is a busy slide but it's just a as
a way of indicating
that in the case of the biomarkers used
in our particular
use case
they have been extensively studied by
many researchers across the globe and
have consistently been demonstrated to
be highly prognostic
for
disease progression in chronic kidney
disease
so we didn't need to depend on one paper
or two papers or one study
or two studies we were able to leverage
quite a depth of literature
which comes from
early engagement and early
enthusiasm from
so many world-class clinical researchers
and biomarker researchers who who saw
the early publications and and took it
upon themselves in collaboration with
others to
to expand the data data set around these
biomarkers which ultimately
led to them being able to be translated
into clinical practice
having
gone through that
stage of development
which is really a
feasibility and a credibility phase
we've been able to demonstrate
that these biomarkers truly add
independent information over existing
clinical features
lots of studies have been done to
demonstrate that they have both
biological and clinical
relevance
and there's evidence to support that
importantly as i mentioned on the
previous slide replication and
validation
across multiple cohorts
with multiple ethnicities represented in
those cohorts
and very importantly that there is a
very defined and verifiable set of
outcomes that the biomarkers are being
tested against
whether that's in in the case of chronic
kidney disease that's really you're
you're really trying to ensure that
there is a consistency in terms of what
the biomarkers are being associated with
in chronic immune disease the hardest
outcome or the outcome that's most uh
measurable i guess and
and
indisputable is where a patient has
moved on to end-stage renal disease
requiring dialysis or transplantation
where that can take
quite a lot of time and therefore
in a lot of disease conditions and
particularly in chronic illnesses you
look for surrogate outcomes and then
surrogate outcome for for end-stage
renal disease in in our case would be a
progression in in kidney function
decline so you're looking for a
measurable decline in kidney function
over a defined period of time which is
indicative of
that patient's risk of moving on to
the catastrophic event of end-stage
renal disease so having really clearly
defined and verifiable outcomes is very
important in this
translation journey
then the practicalities kick in in terms
of your what is the sample
how accessible is it and can be handled
in a way that will allow
the analyzer the biomarkers to be
measured repeatedly and reproducibly
um sample types are are many you know
you'll be familiar obviously with things
like urine and plasma serum
also you have
tumor tissue samples and other biopsy
derived
sample types that are used in biomarker
research and biomarker translation in
our particular case we're looking at
predominantly serum and urine in in the
chronic kidney disease space or sorry
plasma and urine
right now we're looking we're measuring
our biomarkers in plasma
but we have to make sure that we
understand how stable is the analyte in
that
medium how stable is it during handling
and transport transportation
and then ultimately what level of
standardization is available to make
sure that once we measure those
biomarkers that we can do so repeatedly
and reproducibly and one measure will be
um
the same the same measurement would be
the same day and day out
[Music]
and then as i mentioned previously
understanding the actionable information
and what the clinical need is
must be clearly defined before you move
beyond this early stage of biomarker
translation
so having having addressed all of those
criteria the next step really then is do
is to move into the product development
the cycle of development
and then making sure that that
development is executed in accordance
with the relevant
regulatory frameworks
in this new world of
ai derived
models ai algorithms in our case a
combination of an ai algorithm with
biomarkers not only do you have the
the traditional regulatory frameworks of
us fda
european medicine's hdce marking
and laboratory standards such as clsi
and and clea you also have
data security and privacy considerations
so everything we do and the software
that
underpins some of the work that we do in
terms of developing these biomarker
tests
must be developed and validated in
accordance with those regulations
and personal security and data security
and integrity is is is paramount in all
of these situations
given that context what is clear is what
the the beginning of any
translational process is really
understanding the requirements what are
they what is the
test of what is the biomarker
application that you're really focused
on
and i'm going to speak a little bit
about that on the next slide but i want
to
stress that that's uh really the the
secret to success here is in in making
sure that again with the multiple
stakeholders involved that we have a
clear understanding of what it is we're
trying to address
will it have an impact will it provide
information that was going to be
actionable and documenting and capturing
those requirements
is key
in having done so then you've got to
focus on the asset you want to know that
you can measure these biomarkers you've
got to go through your asset development
cycles uh
you're picking your platform picking
your acid reagents and making sure you
have all of those critical reagents
available that you can bring into a
regulated framework
if there's an algorithm you've got to
develop and train that algorithm in
large data sets and derive the cutoffs
that you're going to use for the
diagnostic test cut off being the
differentiation between
disease no disease low risk high risk
whatever the particular suitable for
therapy are not suitable for her therapy
depending on what are those
use cases to cut the requirement for cut
offs will be different
and
more more often than not
all of these diagnostic tests today
and biomarker test today involve
software so whether that's software
that's embedded in in an existing
laboratory instrument
or a software portal that's used to to
generate an algorithmic derived risk or
all of that needs to be again developed
controlled and validated
and then you move to the cycle of
validation i won't go through all of
that in great detail but you
i do want to emphasize that there are
guidance principles there for all of
these
uh steps from from the regulatory
agencies and specifically in relation to
analytical validation i'm very fortunate
to have very clear guidelines provided
by the clsi and i have a slide later on
that kind of highlights some of those
guidelines around analytical validation
but the same applies for software
validation and clinical validation
which you then ultimately
you execute to provide
the
the objective evidence
that your
biomarker test is
doing what it says it proports to do so
are you providing the information
that you are claiming that the biomarker
can do and then you move to your
regulatory processes and ultimately into
clinical impact and utility
assessment so just to take into a little
bit briefly go to a little bit more
detail in some of those uh requirements
gathering uh an important thing is
again the clinical use case what is the
intended use
what is the what is the information that
the biomarker is is going to provide and
what sort of performance expectations
are are
govern the use of this test and those
performances expectations can include
things like sensitivity absolute risk
specificity
etc
at this point one always thinks about
risk what is the risk of of this
biomarker
giving the wrong information that could
result in incorrect treatment decisions
so that that is is something that you
must consider very early in the process
so that you immediately begin to start
to mitigate those risks as you go to the
validation process
indicated use is slightly different
in that indicated use is for it defines
the
the patient profile
that the test is going to be used on and
again this is something that needs to be
very clearly defined is it depending on
whether it's a screening test a
diagnostic test or a companion
diagnostic
understanding what is the
entry level if you like for for the test
is very important and that can be based
on clinical characteristics disease
stage
stages or or patient demographics
we talked a little bit about the sample
how would be handled and the important
point here is the clinical context of
use will it will will inform the target
turnaround time
so knowing whether that
biomarker results needs to be made
available to the physician in an icu to
make a decision around a
potential sepsis situation is completely
different to something that will be used
to as a as a prognostic test for a
chronic condition like
uh
in ckd where a five-day turnaround time
might be sufficient where in the case of
an icu situation in case of sepsis a
five hour turnaround time is probably
too long so you're looking at completely
different
conditions of of how the biomarker would
be measured and deployed in clinical
practice
a lot of work goes into figuring out how
you're going to measure it and and
sometimes a lot of the research work
that's done that initially is involved
in the discovery of the of the biomarker
may not be something that can be used in
clinical practice therefore you need to
have a translation of
of the assay method from from a research
method into a
to a fully regulated uh
and and
commercially available platform
so that that includes the instruments
itself the reagents that are used and
the availability of any reference
standards or calibrators that may be
needed in in executing the test
understanding how the test will be
presented how the test result will be
presented is it a single measurement
you know is it a single buyer market
that will be reported out against
a a global cutoff for example
troponin eye which is used to to rule it
as a test in the emergency unit
for patients presenting with chest pain
or potential
heart attack
it has a a well-known internationally
established cutoff for whether a patient
is truly encountering a heart attack or
whether it's just a in a non sim
symptomatic chest pain
so in some biomarkers you will have the
the luxury of a global cut off other
times you you don't and you have to
establish those cut-offs
in our case we establish a cutoff to our
algorithmic training cycle where we
where we established a set of
uh criteria where we wanted to put a
certain number of the patient population
into low risk and a certain number of
population to a high risk and we define
our cutoffs accordingly which is based
on a probability of an event occurring
so again without getting into the
specifics
one need to consider
what cut cutoffs are required how many
cutoffs are required is it a single rule
in a rule out is it a is it binary test
or is there multiple
categories that are going to be reported
and whether you will use a a cut off at
all or whether you just provide a
continuous risk score on a on a
continuous scale
thereafter once you've addressed those
uh
many questions then you can start to
plot your way towards regulatory
approval and commercial implementation
so very briefly to touch on and i'm not
sure whether the slides would be
available to you but you know there are
we do have the availability of very good
standards around guiding this activity
and as i mentioned the availability of
the clia sorry the clsi guidelines um
for for analytical validation are
really to go to uh references for for
how to
conduct analytical validation
so then maybe to touch on uh
the importance of dissemination and
publication and in our case you know all
of the work that we've done both in
terms of analytical validation on the
bottom right hand corner
uh to clinical validation on the
left-hand side
all of that data is
is is made available to the users of the
of the test
through through publication and
dissemination and to all the regulatory
uh literature that we
would create
but most early adopters in particular
will
will refer to the to the peer-reviewed
publications that underpin
uh the biomarker test itself
i mentioned the
you know the multiple stakeholders that
are involved in biomarker development
and translation
um
a number of people on on in in this
event will
will be participants in in the in this
in this area
academic and clinical research is really
where a lot of this begins a lot of the
biomarker discovery work is done in
academic and clinical research centers
around the globe
uh we're fortunate to work with some
leading researchers in that area
including jasmine diabetes center
university of michigan and the
university of medical center cronican
it's important to stress the importance
of our partners in
in the pharmaceutical and diagnostics
industry
without which there would not be
the level of development and translation
of biomarkers we have today
we work with with a number of those
namely uh janssen and astrozenica in
certain respects but we also work with
diagnostics manufacturers such as
biotechni and lisa scale
in in developing their our platforms
what what pharma
diagnostics companies bring is is a
clearly defined needs
they also help to bring
biobanks and samples that can help to
not only develop or to validate
biomarkers and obviously to bring the
expertise in the development of the
critical materials that are required to
to allow these
biomarkers get into clinical practice
as as biomarkers move into the into the
clinical practice then you need to
develop real world evidence that there
are these tests are beginning to have an
impact
we uh
put a lot of emphasis on that through
this whole new paradigm that people hear
about all the time around real-world
data translating into reward evidence
and we were executing a number of reward
evidence studies in the us across
multiple health systems on thousands of
patients to to demonstrate
in real world over time the impact that
these new biomarkers can have
on informing clinical care
lastly you've got the advocacy groups
national kidney foundation
patient patient groupings
american diabetes association all of
which have a shared interest in making
sure that these new therapies and sort
of new
biomarker tests and new information is
made available to patients as as
expediently as possible
without their support and without their
um
guidance to some extent uh
you will ultimately not be able to
change clinical practice so
you know obviously the
key role for some of these organizations
is in in outlining guidelines and and
you know there are constantly reviewing
and updating guidelines based on
evidence to support new new medical
technologies new diagnostics and new
therapies so they're they're very much a
a partner or a stakeholder in in this
overall translation
[Music]
i'm not going to spend a lot of time on
this guide other than to
echo what many people
will say in that the earliest
involvement or the earliest engagement
of all the stakeholders in a development
process the better and this
schema here speaks specifically around
the development of a companion
diagnostic
in the area of precision medicine where
you're looking for
a specific biomarker test that will
inform a specific therapy
to be used on a particular patient
the key point here is earlier earliest
engagement
the better where both the diagnostic or
the biomarker and
our biomarkers and the therapeutic are
being developed along the same
pipeline
so then to wrap up with some some key
challenges and opportunities many of
which i will have
touched on already um
one is early engagement and partnership
uh is critical i think it is it is a
convergence of
data
diagnostics biomarker research
pharmaceutical uh
development precision medicine
dation centers uh
medicine all of these things bring
together the opportunity for early
engagement in partnership and making
sure that all of this ethnic biomarker
research does actually get translated to
the patient at the end of the day
from a from a
regulatory point of view again same
principle applies the earlier the
engagement the better um
so it is very important that as as we
begin to
look at the role of these biomarkers in
clinical practice that we
we try to make sure that they are
developed in accordance with the
regulatory requirements and and having
that early involvement in terms of
understanding the risk benefit equation
is very important
access to retrospective biobanks and
linked data sets is is really really
critical a lot of people around the
globe are now developing disease
registries which is which is fantastic
uh
randomized control trials have have been
as a
very fruitful
source of of
biobanks and and biospecimens links to
data all of which can not just serve to
fill the gap in terms of biomarker
discovery but also in terms of biomarker
validation
so you use of
these biobanks the generation of real
world evidence by our banks and disease
registries
all serve to
to advance the ability to translate
these biomarkers into clinical practice
the next
and finally just to
reiterate that you know
in today's world you can't get away from
the data boom if you if for one of a
better word
and and the ability to access data and
the ability to incorporate that data
into advanced analytics and advanced
algorithms together with the with the
contemporary biology coming from the
biomarkers really serves to
to to advance the whole area of
precision medicine
so
that's that's no different in oncology
than it is in chronic conditions such as
chronic kidney disease and i think that
is something that is going to hurl
significant innovation
as it has already done so but even i
think that's going to even be
accelerated
in the years to come
so with that i just wish to thank
everybody for listening and uh
hope you enjoyed the rest of the event
and if anybody wanted to reach out to me
i'm available at the
email address showing on on the screen
right now
thank you very much